[Music]  thank you  [Music]  look at that suit it's cool thanks you  too Cyclone Smasher and I was your time  not me I don't fly I get big that's what  I do  foreign  in cinemas now  my son sacrificed his life to save me  these powers  are not a gift  but a curse  born out of Rage  [Music]  this Loose Cannon needs to be locked  down  for innocent people start getting hurt  he's been asleep for 5 000 years  you find us a cell that can hold we'll  take care of the breath who's on the  team  I didn't bring a passport you don't need  passports  for the Justice Society  we're here to negotiate your peaceful  surrender  I'm not peaceful  no do I Surrender  here we go  I kneel before no one  you didn't come here to seek Justice  we came to exact Revenge  [Music]  chance  I never said I was a hero  you believe you are not worthy  but fate does not make mistakes  [Music]  you had two parts  you can be the destroyer of this world  [Music]  or you can be its savior  [Music]  thank you